I'm not here on my own today very
excited because I'm here with Steve
Kaufman Heidi all right are you I'm fine
thank you
I find and I'm glad we're very far away
so I'm glad that we've been able to find
a time that works so I'm in the UK
you're in Vancouver correct actually I'm
not I'm in Palm Springs California we go
over I can I come down here when it
starts raining in Vancouver we came out
here so we can see the Sun I mean that's
an exaggeration but it's very pleasant
sounds nice oh that sounds much better
than weather actually I say that the
weather's been very warm here today so I
shouldn't complain too much oh okay so I
can see there's a lot of people in the
chat already so I will be in the chat
with use if you have any questions any
comments that you want to ask Steve will
be kind of doing it quite casual as we
go but Steve I'm gonna hand over to you
now to kick off and tell us all about
link and how to power up our language
learning with Lync okay so I think
actually begin for ask why explaining
the search genesis of link I'm a firm
believer as many of you those of you who
know me know I'm a firm believer in the
importance of input and the importance
of meaningful compelling comprehensible
input it's through the input that we
acquire the language it's not because a
teacher instructs us in the fine points
of grammar and a lot of what we absorb
we don't know quite how we absorb all
this stuff why we start accumulating
words but it has a lot to do with how
much we are able to read and listen but
there's more to it than that obviously
so link really is simply a place like
you have to keep people motivated it has
to be a pleasant experience so it's a
place to learn it's a place that
organizes all the different things you
need in order to succeed in a way that
we hope is pleasant and if it's Pleasant
people continue doing it and if it's not
pleasant a lot of people stop doing it
so the whole idea is to make it
convenient and pleasant so that people
feel good about themselves and therefore
the
feel motivated to continue and as long
as they continue listening and reading
and perhaps reviewing words and
occasionally checking the rules of
grammar to remind themselves or to
discover something they have noticed as
long as they keep doing this they're
gonna learn so so link is simply an
environmental all right so let me know
maybe try and share the screen and go
over some of you may be new to link so
I'll go over it it's impossible to go
over everything that's there however
some of you may have specific questions
and I'd be happy to answer those but
let's begin by sharing the screen here
so we will go in to let's see how this
works
you are screen sharing all right now I
am right now I am learning Persian and
Arabic however not many of your viewers
probably can really turns in or Arabic
so I decided to use Spanish and maybe a
little bit of French to show how the
system works
mostly I'm going to be on our web
version the browser version but then I'm
gonna briefly show you the mobile
version because I think as many people
use the mobile version as use the
browser version remember - you can use
the browser version on your mobile
device as well but we have an app for
mobile devices and I will briefly
demonstrate the app as well so here we
are in the library in Spanish alright so
here you can see that you can click on
this and you have a lot of other
languages that you can learn now these
little numbers are the number of words
that theoretically I know in these
languages so I don't know many words in
English because I haven't studied
English at link so the system can only
keep track of your activities on the
system so I've been very active in
Russian at link I have very active in
Italian Portuguese Korean Czech
Ukrainian Romanian and these are sort of
an indication of of where you are this
is your sort of
passive vocabulary count bearing in mind
that it's done by the system
so therefore the word run runs running
ran those are four different words
because the system cannot distinguish if
this is part of the word family run or
not so these numbers are going to be
somewhat inflated for languages that are
very inflected and less inflated for
languages that are less effective but
it's a mouthful it's an indication of
how far along you are but we're going to
say in Spanish now can I just yeah I
haven't done a question can you learn
any language on link well hmm probably
no because you could use a slot like if
you go here and I mean we got good
jarate Bulgarian Esperanto or whatever
there's lots of languages but if you
wanted to learn you know we are adding
Georgian by the way we have languages if
people create content for us and sort of
the minimum is serve 60 we have these
mini stories if we have 60 mini stories
in our language we add the language even
as in the case of Bulgarian and Gujarati
where there's not a big demand for the
language if we have the content because
if someone comes to link and say pays
$10 a month and expects to study Tibetan
and we have no content in Tibetan and
they can't find any content in Tibetan
then basically we're misleading them so
we really don't want to open up a
language now there are people who would
use this lot or say Latin which that
don't intend to study and they can try
studying some other language there it
doesn't work very well and also it
messes up our Latin section because then
we end up with a lot of you know
dictionary definitions that don't relate
to that language so we don't recommend
people doing it so the short answer is
if you're really interested in the
language get some people to create some
content for us and then we all all to
load up the language okay thank you but
there are 34 languages so there's a lot
of languages there
so if we look at the page here as it
presents itself it it can be a little
overwhelming for people but you know a
lot of things are overwhelming at first
if I look at how I was just looking at
my Arabic grammar book and the stuff
that people try to explain to you up
front it's too much you have to
gradually get into something play with
it
discover a few things ask a few
questions read the instructions again
and slowly you get used to how a system
works but here you see that in Spanish I
haven't been active in Spanish so my I
haven't been achieving my daily goal we
can see here I don't have a street going
nothing's happening I have no known
words no links no nothing so I am not
active in Spanish I have in the past on
occasion use Spanish to improve my
Spanish and so I have a total of 19,000
known words in Spanish so if we look at
the things you can do here you can go
look for a tutor you can go to the
community most people will not have
admin I have admin on my version okay
and you can go to the library so we're
gonna look first at the library so we
have a thing here called the lesson fee
and the lesson feed is simply what
people have been studying so if you
follow people the swiss steven here is a
member or je r de d king as a member and
you'll see what they have been studying
you may want to study one of those items
we also are able to go to newspapers
where we scrape as it's called articles
from newspapers and these show up in the
feed and these are not in a sense it
basically as if we placed a link there
except instead of placing a link there
this is now integrated with the link
system so just to quickly go over the
content because in language learning
having interesting content is
tremendously important so you can go to
the lesson feed you
for popular lessons there are even sort
of guided courses separated by you know
level you can browse the library you can
even go to the store and you'll find our
friend
you recognize our friend yes I recognize
sorry I done meet myself but yes very so
this is only Richards series so in the
store you buy content because most of
the content is free it comes to us from
various sources but we also offer high
quality material which we sell and so
you buy the course so I think that's
enough
oh and you can also import so this is
important because as you progress in the
language you may find that the material
you know although we have a tremendous
amount of material in the library maybe
you want to do something else but we
have over a tremendous variety of things
in the library podcasts news business
entertainment sports technology we have
European Spanish Latin American Spanish
but if for whatever reason you want to
do something else like I have in
learning polish I imported whole ebooks
so you can import the holy book and then
buy the audiobook and while you can't
split the summaries too much work to
split the sound up to match the book as
this comes into link you can import
newspaper articles podcasts I've been
doing this in Arabic I I transcribe
podcasts and import them so you can
import content alright now if you open
up a lesson let's say here we open that
up it's at best
alright so here is this story or
whatever it is
la bruja or other I don't know what it
is and we open it this is
and becomes and the system has to go
through and see your known words and a
whole bunch of stuff that tells you so
when you open it I discovered that in my
case there are all these blue words are
words that I have not previously seen at
link and therefore the system considers
them new words I may in fact know some
of these words okay the yellow words are
words that I have previously encountered
that link I may have forgotten the
meaning I may have forgotten that I ever
saw them before but the system knows
that I have seen these before so if and
the white words are white are words that
I have at some time or other either not
chosen to say or I have studied them
through flashcards or whatever and they
are now known so all of the white words
are known words so this is page one here
you can see that you can page your way
through there's a total of 142 new words
in this particular lesson and there are
28 words that you have previously
encountered in which you can review and
we'll show you that a little bit later
but if I look at Thomas HIV sorrow okay
okay you can turn off the text-to-speech
you have it on but I tend to have it on
so I click on it I hear the
text-to-speech and then I choose now 123
means that 123 other users of link have
chosen this as the meaning of the word
there you can also go to other
dictionaries you know I personally like
context reversal the context reversal
has a verb conjugation dictionary you
can add more dictionaries whichever
dictionary you want if you happen to be
a German speaker or a Japanese speaker
you can add a dictionary that works for
your language so there's lots of
different dictionaries that you can add
there's no let end of dictionaries but
these are the dictionaries that I have
so I'm in whoops
so yeah okay now the next thing is once
you open this up now is our own
now normally a translation would have
appeared in there I think I messed it up
but anyway crossed okay sorry
draught you can add you can change the
hint you can put whatever you want in
there but you also see that this is now
from uh Travis ah it's a verb it's the
pretending to perfecto simply it's the
third person okay and so if this tells
you you can save one of these this is
sort of an because you can tag stuff you
can tag any word or phrase that you say
you can tag it you can tag it for
subjunctive you can tag it for medical
terms that enables you then to look up a
list of these tag items in your
vocabulary section for a sort of a
concentrated review but one of the other
neat things is okay and identifies it as
a verb if you click on verb you are
taken to a grammar resort Spanish verb
tenses because it's kind of useful and
you can look at different things if you
want but it's kind of useful to kind of
review grammar from time to time I find
that it's very difficult to absorb
grammar explanations upfront but that
every so often you're curious like what
what form of the verb is this or why
you're and therefore it's good to kind
of review the grammar from time to time
so we now are able to identify not in
all languages but in many languages we
are able to identify what part of speech
and provide some grammar explanation
there is in every Latin again not in
every language but in a lot of languages
if you look at this earth your picture
here your profile there is a grammar
guide so you know we have in fact we
contracted with people to provide us
with a grammar guide for most of our
languages maximum six thousand words so
as a concise grammar guide in you know
Greek or Dutch sure whatever it might be
so that's kind of useful to know so what
the main tasks at link is to go through
and say okay Lina
Lita is a name I don't like this name so
I ignore the word because I don't want
leader in my word count Lee doesn't it
leer and all the white word but it's not
added to my links initially money in
that Larry said and I don't know what
thou thy money on is but I have the
feeling that I'm not that interested in
that either so you can basically or
let's see popular translations no ok or
you take it easy say money in that very
second so now I have saved that whole
phrase which is the other you know
option you can save words or phrases so
for example El comedor
who you lose Sahiba antenna and oh ok
incoming that kooyenga Kuya is kind of a
useful handy word to you to know so you
save the phrase I mean that we can say
that the malanga so you can add a tag if
you want maybe you know you might want
to tag say relative pronoun or something
depending how how grammatical you are
you can do that alright so you add that
so you go through I can go and oh I know
this word Montanez say I know this word
this job on flash they say yeah that's
kinda I want that or if the way I'm set
up if I simply go on to the next one it
will save it so it's using the arrow
keys you can automatically move to the
next blue word common solace yeah I'll
take that so you take that you can hit
answer as you can go press your cursor
on it
los rios yeah retractors we need to be
reminded that red Toronto is a portrait
it's not a retired person for example
you know and so you know we can I could
just hit enter and I've got a couple
The Apprentice is like being a director
I know that word so I'm not gonna bother
saving it I can it k4 known for example
that's why so there are a number of
little keystrokes like that that you PU
the objective is to go through the text
now if I hit this little arrow here I
get to review the money in a second ok
so and because my own view of flashcards
is that they are simply a concentrated
exposure to the language
I don't like racking my brain and
therefore I put all the information on
the front of the flash drive so all I've
done is I've isolated four or five items
in the page that I don't feel
comfortable or confident of and
therefore I review them in a
concentrated manner before moving on to
the next page but I don't force myself
to try to remember anything I'm not a
big fan of forcing myself to try to
remember anything
I just find it annoying and not very
effective but here you can you know you
can for example you have different
settings so I'm in the review area I can
choose for example I've avoided the
close test I've avoided dictation
dictation can be very effective but it
takes more time consuming I can have
multiple choice not have multiple choice
cards per session so there's a number of
things that I can do you know similarly
I can there are settings for the reader
area
you know I've dictionary languages text
size I can choose my text-to-speech
accent for example Latin American
Spanish whatever I want so there are a
number of settings similarly with the
home setting I can choose to include a
guided course Europe in Spanish there
are a number of things you know
library topics so again I can't get into
all of these details I'll be forever but
let's just say that there are a lot of
settings instead and people should
familiarize themselves with those I'm
now on the next page so I go through the
same thing again go through and if I see
you know Sione's arms here yes yeah I
think I know that so I can now move this
along it's just it's a status one word
because that's what happens the first
time you change it to you know yellow
but you might feel more comfortable not
totally comfortable but you might
magically move to a status three once
it's a status for it's not okay
status for is known but it still reviews
in your SRS feed you know in 30 days but
if you give it a tick you won't see it
again it's gone insofar as regularly
reappearing when you're reviewing them
just to confirm that one I just want to
fix your screen that so you decide
yourself how confident you feel about a
word and then it will go through the SRS
system on the flash cards is that
correct that is to say the status to
determines how frequently they reappear
in your SRS feet when you go through
your flash cards if you get want to
write twice it also moves along in
status okay so you're not always
necessarily being the one to decide
sometimes it will know that in my own
case because I don't do a lot of flash
card because I just find that you know I
have so many thousands of words that
I've saving that if I did I would spend
all my time on flash cards yeah or I do
a lot of reading and when I and I just
find that over time as I read more and
more of these yellow words I know them
and so or I feel more confident about
them and and part of my motivation as I
look at this screen I just like to get a
lighter in color I like to get it whiter
I like to get it into a lighter tone of
yellow and so I kind of move things
along and I would say most of the words
that I some words just disappeared so I
must have gone through flashcards or
something that I know them but I find
that very often I manually simply
manually move them along while reading
you can also manually move them along in
the vocabulary section but again the
vocabulary section
I just find that everything that takes
me away from listening and reading I'm
less motivated to do
that's me to earn not other people may
be different and they spend may spend
more time in the vocabulary section
thank you
yeah so just some other things again I
don't know quite what the best thing so
I could go through the flashcards in
more detail but it's been fairly
straightforward most people know what a
closed test is what a flashcard is what
a multiple choice is dictation you hear
the phrase or the word and that can be a
very useful thing to do is is to go in
and deliberately save a whole bunch of
phrases in a page let's say if I were to
go through this page and save ten
phrases and then go and do my flashcards
and set in my settings set it only to
dictation then I would have to hear
those phrases in Spanish text-to-speech
mind you and I would have to write them
up I would have to type them in because
that's what dictation is you hear it so
if I let's just do that for now let's
say we go here today to look okay that's
multiple choice but let's say then we go
in there review settings and we don't
want to do flash current we don't sit in
Traverse flashcards hitting on a
multiple choice we just want to do the
case you sit it to look close okay so
now today to look see the tool okay so
now I have to type in city and it has
these little special keys well you know
they're allowed and the accent then and
then Enya and stuff like that to help us
a lot so we submit hey I got it right
okay
next it's clever its travel
it's tirado okay let's see what happens
oh this is another way like so with the
review it's important you can set it up
to do whatever you want you can just do
close to us you can just do flowers
cards but the dictation especially when
I was learning Greek and Arabic I found
a very useful because it's so hard to
get
used to the new writing system so just
focusing on you know dictation was very
effective but then again it's also very
good sometimes to have all five because
variety is good randomness is good so
you don't get bored doing the same thing
there's different stuff coming energy
okay getting back to our lesson page
here so this happens to be so these are
this is my lesson feed in Spanish but oh
yeah so let's just go over to whatever
you had let's see so we are in Spanish
let's go to French just to show you that
in French again I don't have many words
here in French but in fact I know French
but well I just haven't studied it here
so here and the other thing is you can
set it always defaults to my lessons for
me because I said it to default to my
lessons but I can have a default to
whatever I want
okay I can have a default of vocabulary
or to playlist so then who every time I
open this up it'll default to wherever I
want it to be I personally find it
useful to default to my lessons close
one of the things I so therefore yeah so
I could open any of these and start
studying them if I go to the library
sometimes it's interesting to see what
have people been studying because that
can be motivating to oh so-and-so has
been doing Victor Hugo or her de Menken
piece or whatever it is and I might want
to study one of those lessons and I see
right away that this lesson for me has
28% new words now that's not realistic
because in fact I know French very well
and almost those words but I haven't
been doing in a link right so this one
is 41% but for someone who has been
studying hard at link if that number is
you know 10% new words 15 that's
comfortable
whereas 40% new words might be too
difficult so they can go in and find
something with a lower percentage
new word to stop I also want to mention
the fact that the playlist is quite
useful the playlist and I don't have
anything obviously in there much in
French but if I were to show you that
lets let's have a look here if I go to
my Farsi here and I look at let's see if
I look at ok I can add ok has already
been added to play this but if I look at
my let's see lessons and if I look at my
no I don't want to repair my street away
if I go to playlist you will see that I
have lots lots of items on my playlist
lots and this is the playlist
automatically shows up on all your
devices so as you're studying you can
save the sound file to a playlist so
that I if I have my iPhone with me I've
always got these lessons to listen to
and if I'm listening to one and I'm a
little bit confused on quickly get to
the text to read to make sure that I
understand what I'm listening to
so so the the playlist it's very
important and also tells you how many
times you have listened to these items
so I have listened to some of the East
fifteen eighteen times if I go back to
my earlier and what that's like
here storing one two three four five I
listen to thirty or forty times so it
also helps track your listening because
we do have these statistics you know I'm
wondering a bit because I want to finish
at 9:30 and then turn it over to
questions otherwise we'll go forever
here but statistics are key because
statistics keep you motivated and so if
I look at sort of my profile it's very
interesting
so that okay in my Persian okay I can
look at the last seven days but I can
also look at all time so here's a
history
my engagement with Persia and these are
my own words but I can also look at you
know the amount that I listen listening
and the listening tracks based on when
you listen to the lesson while studying
the lesson but it also tracks the last
thing you do in on your iPhone or mobile
device and so I see that you know I did
a little bit of sort of listening here
back in the summer when I first bought a
book and I bought some material and then
I didn't do anything as I was preparing
to go to Morocco so I was focusing on
Arabic and then since the beginning of
the year when I returned from Morocco I
have been doing both Persian and Arabic
and so all of a sudden my numbers are
off if I look at other languages that I
have learned for example the one that
I've done the longest is Russia and if I
look at for example links created which
is a good indicator of of your level of
activity I see that I was very active in
2007 and then less and less active of
course as you go along or another I
think interesting one is the known words
where again I find that you pick up
speed after a while so I struggle
struggle struggle struggle and then I
start really adding a lot of known words
I'm not at that stage in Persian and
Arabic but and for someone who's an inny
speaker we're doing Spanish or French
there's so many words that are quickly
recognized that the growth in the known
words is actually quite wrapped up
anyway so those are things you can do
you can go to your profile and see your
history in the language but let's get
back now to our Spanish page very
quickly tutors if you want a tutor you
can look up and choose one and I'm not
going to go through the process of
scheduling a session with the tutor but
they can set their own prices and you
can talk to them my activities shows
that what if you have anything scheduled
a little shop here the community takes
you to the forum you know I can go on
for a long time
I think I should stop it there and let
people ask questions and so should I
should I leave the share screen up for
now feel free to bring it back to your
to your face so we can check I'm very
excited by those statistics I'm a bit
over nerd when it comes to that kind of
stuff so that's cool I like that yes
stop sharing yeah okay yeah six are cool
because and you can look at what other
people are doing but more than that that
the graphic representation of your level
of activity over the last month over six
months over and like you forget when did
I start studying check when was I most
active and checked when was I adding the
most words and it's just tremendously
motivated it is like I can't imagine if
I had was that going back to 2007 is
that the earliest that you had it on
there yeah yeah I mean Korea and I was
fairly early dividing Russian is the
earliest yeah I can't imagine if I had
like a record of all the contact I'd had
with all my languages you feel I feel so
much more confident as well about I
don't you know what I am good at this I
have spent the time on this that's so
cool it is cool and and it's very
interesting
the sort of non words thing so I was
doing the other day a little workshop on
it but you know in you can actually
learn a lot of words if you do a lot of
listening and reading you do you learn a
lot of words but obviously if you are a
Spanish speaker learning Portuguese I
mean you automatically got this massive
vocabulary right even when I learned
Romanian I learned 20,000 words in a
month because 70% of the words are like
Italian on the other hand with Greek or
with Arabic or with Persian it's a lot
slower obviously but you pick up speed
because you see first of all there's a
lot of words that are forms of other
words and you start to understand how
the language works and you understand
more and more of a context and so that
growth in your vocabulary
starts to accelerate and you can then
see that graphically and
then it peeks at a certain point and
then it dies off a little bit because
you're not acquiring as many new words
obviously here you're dealing with with
words of lower and lower frequency all
the time yeah that's true that's true
oh cool okay um so I'm gonna go to the
questions I've got a few that I saved
from earlier I think this actually links
what you were just talking about Spanish
and Portuguese so Dennis said I speak
French at an advanced level level German
intermediate and Spanish at a beginner
to intermediate level and find in
watching videos where a French speaker
is teaching Spanish or vice versa helps
me improve what are your thoughts on
using your strongest foreign language to
learn another well you know several
thoughts first of all when I learn
another you know a new language
my focus is the new language so I'm sort
of in the new language if I use a
dictionary I'm in and out of that
dictionary as quickly as I can be I just
want to get back to the text so that I
get used to making meaning out of the
target language but it's true that if I
you know you may have seen that I have
Russian on as one of my other dictionary
languages it's fun to see the meaning in
another language it can sometimes have a
slightly different nuance and of course
any exposure to a language that you've
already studied is gonna reinforce like
it may only be a a grain of sand but
it's it's a small degree of
reinforcement so as long as what you see
that any explanation is clear to you
then I think it's a good thing to do if
it takes you to a language that you
don't know very well and the explanation
is not clear now you're looking at words
in that language to me that's a
distraction from the target link but if
what you get in terms of a translation
or an explanation is clear in your
second or third language I think it's
it's in many ways that are very good to
do so as you're strong enough to
understand everything so you're not
having to look up twice great yeah yeah
cool fan Sue's asked is Hungarian close
to being added on linked
one person volunteered and has
translated 15 stories and submitted
audio samples which I listened to and
they were good and it's now in the hands
of our virtual assistants or an who
lives in summer in Serbia and he'll be
working with this person and whoever
else is is we're collaborating with him
or her and we should have them but I
can't give you a deadline okay okay in
the pipeline in the pipeline in the
pipeline that's good enough Kevin asks I
know we can add our own materials but
can we as teachers create materials for
our students and share with them via
link okay absolutely
for example one of my favorite type of
content in Arabic and farsi where kind
of I'm sort of in-between I the
beginning materials is boring for me now
and the authentic material is too
difficult I mean I bow my way through it
but it's too difficult when I have my
lessons with my tutors in Farah in
Persian and in Arabic I get back from
them a report that contains a lot of
phrases and words that I had trouble
using either that she explained to me or
that I used incorrectly or I was looking
for a word and she provided the word so
then I get this with a five-minute audio
recording to go with it and and I can go
you know conversation reports is a
course so I go to that I can see all of
my tutor sessions going back however
many months six months eight months and
I can go through them again and again
and again so this is content obviously
that has been created together with my
tutor but not only the tutor any member
can create content
I've had people record their blogs and
put them up that we encourage people to
do that there's a fellow in Egypt who
did a blog on Arabic history culture
unfortunately too difficult for me but
obviously if we can get tutors or other
members native speakers all we require
is audio and text and very often if it's
a natural
conversation which is then transcribe
that's the best kind of intermediate
learning material rather than okay you
can record Wikipedia in Romanian but
it's not as good as a natural
conversation which is then transcribed
so we encourage being printed that but
you can but you can't share stuff in the
library that you don't have the rights
to so that's the other caveat right so
if you're a teacher for example you if
you have the rights of something you can
limit that to your group like we can set
it up so that only your group can access
that but we can't make available in our
library material for which there are
copyright issues you want for yourself
anything you want for yourself yeah okay
cool cool so if you you know if you if
you were teaching you created it
yourself from scratch
thank you chair a within your own group
but also that would be able to share
publicly because you'd have the rights
to them we have it we would have to go
if you said okay I'm a teacher I have a
group of twenty students well I have
created this but I only want to share it
with them we set that up as a classroom
environment they are the only ones who
have access to that on the other hand if
you're happy to share it with everyone
in the library that's your choice we
have people who have language teaching
sites who will share ten lessons with us
in order to entice people back to their
website where there are additional
exercises and other things so there's a
number of reasons or ways in which
people share content cool excellent all
right um let me see ah yes that's about
multiple languages we've just we've
discussed a little bit already let me
just check this out a few more maybe
here
okay so Mina asked the listening part is
it the texts read or do you have other
listening materials as well I'm asking
because I want to know for a language
like persian that the written form is
different to spoken one is there any
material just for practicing this broken
form yeah one of the delights of Persian
is this between the spoken and the
written form I would say that our many
stories are in the written form so they
are recorded versions of the written
we have my tutor Rana has also created
many stories in the spoken form if you
if you like there are other resources
like Persian online which I can't share
with others but anyone learning Persian
could go there and import it into link
as I have done and a lot of that is in
this booklet form so bad but we have a
whole series actually not only Rama's we
have another we had we had a person and
his girlfriend sister I don't know they
also created a bunch of conversations in
conversational Persia so we have both we
have both we should probably put some
tags in there so that you can find the
one or the other
but I must admit personally I'm not
bothered by it if I hear it I know it's
the further informers it's the spoke
informant yeah I one says I've been on
link for a while learning Latin my next
project will be classical Greek Wow
I said Snowden you do not want to follow
the usual approach grammar grammar
grammar and more grammar not really
learning do you have any thoughts on how
to approach classical Greek I about it
what I know a little bit I know suggests
that there's a lot of dispute about how
classical Greek Greek was pronounced
unlike Latin where there seems to be
some consensus on how it was pronounced
since our system is based on listening
and reading we wouldn't be able to
accommodate the listening part but I if
I were doing it I would I would find out
you know eat X of classical Greek and
imported into the Greek slot at link so
at least you can read it there and you
have to add ask us to add if it requires
an extra dictionary for classical Greek
we probably could add that classical
dictionary excellent okay and oh yeah
question from Dennis who has already the
$10 a month version of link is that the
level does that give the highest
functionality of link yeah yeah so there
rancor
reduce your cost and make a commitment
for a six month or one year there is not
well the other thing you can do is you
know if you have a tutor you have to pay
the two all right but we have not yet
and we've thought about you know maybe
we should have some system which
includes you know paid content like
Holly Richards material or our stuff
from I mean there are other people who
want to be paid and so you have a higher
you know category where you would get
this premium content and some access to
tutor isn't but we've never done
anything on it's basically to ten
dollars a month or it's discounted if
you commit to a six months or one year
okay so it's nice and simple I like that
I'm not on top of everything that
happens it linked all the time if we
raised our monthly but grandfathered for
existing members but if you buy in the
six month package then of course you're
not saving again so you don't end up
paying more but I think for those people
are playing by the month it's no longer
tennis might be 13 or something
I don't know I don't have the drop I
don't want to get into drama I'm not on
top exactly ten I think when I checked
earlier I put it into UK money it came
out 1199 in UK palaces we did increase
it to $13 us but yeah the idea there is
you shouldn't if you're gonna learn a
language commit to at least six months
yeah I mean you can try it for one month
if you don't like it fine but if you do
it I could commit to six months and then
you're then you're back to where you
were I think it's the way to just seem
yourselves and to see those statistics
as well a little question here we're
almost done I want to give you some time
to get ready for your next session that
you've got going on but don't we're
going to get to all the questions but
here's one about link specifically so I
want to ask this from Dennis does link
have a glossary of who is providing the
text for link so for example I see that
I do which has some material link in one
language maybe neither nother yeah so do
you have a glossary of the author's
there's chairman
yeah you know I should know these things
better but if we go to settle up here go
to the library and okay so search I
think there is library browse library no
there was so you can set the level of
difficulty there was somewhere I should
know this where you can set a filter by
the provider but in any case let's say
we let's see we put in oli there and see
what happens
Holly Richard shows up so you could put
someone's name in there I can't on the
fly our filters though there is
somewhere but I unfortunately I don't
know where it is where you can see the
list of providers so which one did I
skip up here oh yeah there was a
question from Anne can you walk through
the steps to upload the lyrics of a
French song so if you had content
yourself is the other process quite
simple okay so there's two scenarios
there I would say okay should I should I
show that on the screen okay so we will
do that screen share and share so this
you've got to get to the import there's
two ways we're doing it you can get the
link extension for your browser that's
one way of importing things or you go to
the import which you can do here or you
can do from the library but let's say
you click here and you can import a
lesson there is also import an e-book
there's no
you can import okay so you come to this
page so first of all we typically have
on the import page a list of all the
different places where you can go and
find content okay so all three CNN
Cervantes we do all whatever it might be
but let's say that you have a song so
you can either type the song here or
what usually happens is if I go to you
know a mundo what's any text the mundo
which is a newspaper in Spain the are
you online so you get an article here
look let's see
and so you simply copy and paste so you
whoops so here let's say that I take
that grab a copy and then I go to
wherever I was here and then I just put
it in here I now put the text in write
the what the music of the song you
should have it as an mp3 file Parker
than your desktop or somewhere and you
just click upload audio file and then
the URL of that song or the file will
show up here okay you're looking at
reflects I can't hear you by the way I
was in the chat I was just trying to
check the next question so you you
upload the audio you have to give it a
title something like that and then you
save it or save it open oh and you also
have to choose a course so you might put
this in create a course called Spanish
sauce another thing you can do is if you
go to youtube Spanish
songs okay so if you have a YouTube song
that has closed captions and don't want
to take forever here but again I'm not
so smart at doing all this stuff but if
it has post captions you turn on the
closed captions and while that is
playing you click on your extension your
browser extension and then it will open
up as a lesson in link so you will have
a link you will have the text of the
song the text of the closed captions is
that whatever is in the closed captions
will show up as text
the video shows up in video and you
cannot download the song to your
playlist so you could study the song you
can watch the video and then afterwards
while you're out walking the dog you can
listen to it so the Chrome extension is
one way or simply importing is another
way you know what with the time I have
run out of time to demonstrate I just
realized I was gonna demonstrate on the
mobile but the mobile app is very
similar so I don't think it's necessary
to demonstrate that so I think I'll get
back out of sharing screen I hope that
answers the question that does yeah
thank you I'm just like my mind is full
of those things now to import like the
idea so you group them then into courses
which is like but you have another
matter yeah I mean we call them courses
but you've got to organize it somehow or
you'll never fight yeah and you can set
your reader to look up lessons or to
look up courses but the the amount of
content just it just grows exponentially
so unless you have lessons or something
I would say or if you like a particular
singer Julio Iglesias so I would create
a course of Julio Iglesias create a
course so that you can get to the course
and then you can you know drill into
that course and find the lessons there
okay one final question then so it's
come through as anonymous as a very
early beginner is it fine to study
lessons with very high unknown
percentages well obviously when you
start in a language as a beginner it's a
hundred percent on the words so
obviously you have to start at that
point what my strategy is to start with
lessons that are no more than 1 minute
long like 30 seconds to 1 minute mom I
fight my way through the text looking up
all the words obviously if I'm an
English speaker learning Spanish there's
a lot of words that I will recognize if
I'm learning Arabic there's not and I go
through that and I listen several times
and I review and I do more sort of
reviewing in flashcards and stuff and
dictation and stuff at the beginning
because everything is so new to me but I
don't wait until I a hundred percent
master that first lesson before I move
on to the second because I won't master
it everything is too fuzzy and I go two
and three and four and five and then
back to one and and eventually you know
the fog starts to lift but obviously
you're gonna begin with more difficult
content now in my own case I have found
that our many stories which actually
would be the would be considered
intermediate one I start with them in
Arabic and Persian in all of these
languages and I have never progressed as
quickly as I do now and because those
stories are built in such a way that the
vocabulary repeats about three times
four times in the story and all of the
many stories focus on the most common
verbs in the language if you have verbs
you can say stuff now these names of
things is less important names of colors
whatever it doesn't matter
verbs go-come needs say give take want
these are so important and so these
stories focus the first 20 stories in
the present tense thereafter they're in
any pens and even that doesn't really
matter it's not obvious that the present
tense is easier to the past tense it's
just that there's only one tense and so
I found that these which would be
considered somewhat more challenging
than the norm
starting material has worked fine for me
so but I think what's important is the
length and the amount of repetition if
you have a story beginner story and the
words only appear once it's just not
gonna do it you want to have beginner
material where the same vocabulary
repeats and repeats and repeats within
that story and then so on that basis I'd
certainly recommend well you can't start
with anything less than a high percent
on in other words if the language is new
to you so that's a given right yeah well
you know yeah there's many stories I I'm
very very grateful that you join us
today I had no idea honestly how
powerful link really is so thank you for
sharing everything well I do I much
appreciate it the next polyglot
conference where we'll get together
again yes looking forward to it I'll see
you soon
thank you for joining us and thanks for
watching as well if you're on the
recording
you